first we have more troubling news from
the Middle East tonight a $30 million us
Reaper drone was shot out over the sky
over International airspace by Iranian
back you know the houti re uh Rebels and
terrorists in Yemen uh again we must
start out by asking your commander and
chief Joe Biden Mr President what are
you going to do about this meanwhile we
have US soldiers suffering yet another
two attacks at bases in the Middle East
today by other Iranian proxies and so
far there have been 42 attacks against
our US soldiers carried out by Iranian
link terrorists in the past month alone
now Joe's response was to take out two
small empty warehouses and just hours
ago apparently another quote small
retaliatory US air strike against
whatever assets they they hit in Syria
we'll find out sometime in the next day
or two that's it Joe Biden is he's not
going to take any substantial action to
prevent further attacks against American
troops abroad is he going to just you
know keep on bombing empty warehouses
because think about this you know if
China they have all these hostile
actions against American fighter jets in
international airspace no response China
takes hostile actions against our Navy
in international waters well Joe gives
no response China's spy balloon what
happened it got to fly 88 days over our
country over our military installations
no response China's hostile actions over
Taiwan and their Aerospace no response
Russia shoots down our drones no
response is it because Joe wants more
what Financial business deals with China
and Russia that he won't take action
these against these hostile regimes or
is he just a pathetically weak US
president we'll let you answer now
meanwhile back at home anti-Semitism it
is exploding I never thought I'd see
this in our lifetime did anyone ever
think this never thought I would see
this in our lifetime including in the
halls of Congress uh this as Jewish
Americans are now still still being held
hostage by terrorists in a war zone um
and by the way Joe why are you not
demanding the release of all of these
hostages including Americans that are
being held hostage where is your
president tonight I'm sure he's sleeping
I'm sure he doesn't know that today is
Wednesday and as anti-American sentiment
is on the rise and the threat of
terrorism is now spiking is Joe Biden
going to do anything to secure our
Southern border is he going to do
anything at all because we now know the
Department of Homeland Security there
you know there's Alejandro mayorcas
testified today he has no idea at all
how many illegal immigrants are
currently in our country or where
they're from or why they're here we know
what thousands from countries like Iran
Syria other places in the Middle East
Russia China Joe has l in almost 8
million illegal immigrants it may be 10
million by the end of the year this is
insanity and it's just another horrible
chaotic day under President Joe Biden
but according to last night's election
results Americans seem pretty unfaced at
least on the surface we're going to
break all of this down let's start in
the Commonwealth of Virginia where State
Democrats were able to hold on to a slim
majority in the Senate there and pick up
a slim majority in the house of
delegates now some are trying to blame
Governor Glenn yunan and his expansive
get out the vote effort here's the
reality Virginia whether you want to
believe it or not I had given up on
Virginia years ago it is a blue State
it's not even a purple State the anomaly
in Virginia happened two years ago when
Glenn yunan won the governorship there
and he deserves a ton of credit for
trying as hard as he did to flip both
houses and as the federal government by
the way is expanding at a rapid Pace
hordes of government workers the vast
majority 90 plus percent Democrat
relocating just south of DC into
Northern Virginia where taxes are low
schools are better and crime is
relatively low and unfortunately the
vast majority of government workers
they're Democrats so are most of the
employees
at the NOS the law firms and other
groups associated with the government so
Virginia was close because of yonan's
popularity it's a blue state in spite of
what the media what a huge Victory what
a what this is bad for Glenn yunan no
it's not the fact that Glenn yunan won
frankly is a miracle the fact that he
won by the large margin he did was
another miracle it just shows what the
failure of Democrats can do can awaken
people at least temporarily anyway but
once again we do have to talk about the
issue of abortion it was a major issue
yesterday and I do believe deeply in the
sanctity of life I'm I'm pro-life I'm
very open about it but I also recognize
a political truth and reality and that
is that the majority of the American
people as I have been saying for years
people said yesterday Sean Hannity
finally admit no Sean Hannity has been
saying it for years that now the
consensus in this country country a few
years now I've been saying Americans
reject the most restrictive abortion
laws they just do now okay so people can
disagree with me but now they especially
rejected if these restrictions Target
early pregnancies under 15 weeks that's
the political reality I'm not giving you
my personal view I'm telling you what
where where the consensus of the country
is even in the state of Ohio a very red
State now 57% % of Voters there approved
a measure adding abortion rights to the
State Constitution and Democrats now are
using abortion as a political weapon not
only do they accuse Republicans every
two and four years of being racist
sexist misogynist homophobic xenophobic
islamophobic wanting dirty air wanting
dirty water and wanting to kill Grandma
and Grandpa now they're saying that
Republicans will end all abortions which
is a lie and the problem has been
Republicans have not countered that
false narrative in that lie now by the
way this even played a pretty big role
in deep red Kentucky where a very
popular Democratic governor who totally
distanced himself from Joe Biden painted
his opponent Daniel Cameron as a
heartless anti-woman Zealot Republicans
need to spend dollar for dooll every lie
the Democrats tell you must fight back
with ads telling people the truth over
the past two election Cycles Republicans
rarely responded to any of these attacks
especially on abortion they need to
start responding but tonight it is clear
they must fight back they need a
coherent strategy to counter the
abortion narrative or the abortion lie
or this issue will issue will haunt them
in 2024 and Beyond Republicans also need
to buy into early voting and legal
ballot harvesting they can't show up on
Election Day down by hundreds of
thousands of votes and expect to win in
a perfect world there would be just one
election day make it a national holiday
paper ballots voter ID signature
verification chain of custody controls
updated voter roles partisan observers
watching the vote and watching the vote
counting and if we had all of that guess
what we would add Integrity to our
election system and everybody can have
confidence in the result of Elections
that is not the world that we're living
in and by the way Republicans that have
been reluctant and resistant to voting
early and by mail they need to adapt
they need to organize and they need to
beat Democrats at their own game hey
Sean Hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to Fox News YouTube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere
else